hey las vegas i have a question for you
are you ready for the football
yeah
yes we are ready and if you're looking
for a great place to watch the game
tonight you might want to head to
tailgate social inside palace station
here to tell us more about this rockin
raiders party we have aida and chef josh
joining us uh today welcome you guys
thank you awesome thank you for being
here now when it comes to a tailgate
party i think you need two things you
need tvs and you need food talk to me
about the tvs 26 and counting so over 26
tvs
lots of beer we got tvs covered you got
beer covered yep and you've got great
food what are some of the food options
you guys have tonight so tonight we're
going to be doing a raiders burger it's
the first day we're going to have a
special on it it's a primer burger with
onion rings fried jalapenos and a
peppercorn aioli all right chef josh you
need to build this thing for us today
yes nice and what kind of beef is this
this is a 80 20 angus blend
that sounds like good beef to me oh yes
that's football beef right there yeah
and what are some of the other food
options that you guys have this burger
looks delicious that chef is building it
yeah so we have our lv nation burger
which is really we put vegas in a burger
and
hot chicken sandwich pizzas of course
wings you can't go wrong uh all the
tailgate specials hot dog every home
game for the raiders we're going to have
a special with this
las vegas burger versus the home the uh
something signature from the other team
that we're playing okay okay so we're
playing baltimore raven tonight what's
the what's the difference so tonight
we're doing uh baltimore crab cakes oh
that sounds so good no fresh remoulade
and it came out really well but if i'm
rooting for the raiders can i still get
the crab cakes that beans me to do that
definitely we're ready for both oh you
get them both okay you got the burger
built what's in it so we got our angus
our prime rib and then we have a
tailgate cheese it's a special blend of
swiss provolone and aged cheddar
and i made a scratch peppercorn sauce
with a toasted brioche roll
it looks delicious and you know i love
tuna you brought some tunas we bring
some tuna we make a ahi tuna in house
and it's big eye tuna okay why don't we
hold the burger up for everyone to see
here so they can look at this creation
chef josh made look at this thing
hold it out there looks so good mm-hmm
yeah that's bad that's right that
burger's shining right now everyone's
seeing that right now on tv now also at
the game i know you have some great
raffles where's some of the raffles that
you guys have we do we do so we are so
excited we are able to give our
customers the opportunity to win tickets
to go to a home game for the raiders so
just come watch any football game
college
professional football and you get a
rifle ticket and our drawings are on
every sunday when the raiders are
playing away it's huge yeah yeah it's
amazing it's great when it comes to
watching football i know people had to
go down with a group of people if you
got a group of six or something can you
make reservations yeah we can go up to
30 people
this is going to be good it's a good
season guys thank you so much for
joining us we truly appreciate it
definitely thank you thank you all right
rocky i'm gonna eat some tuna and send
it over to you